you guys are looking at me like that guy
doesn't look like a Rodriguez right
there that's Cory Johnson right there
that guy I made a mistake today man I
went to McDonald's before I came here uh
I don't think any adult each McDonald's
nowadays and when they're done eating it
they're like that was delicious I think
even with kids eat McDonald's are like
my stomach hurts but I want to go back
tomorrow McDonald's is the only food you
eat and you know you messed up when it's
in your throat it doesn't even have to
get to your stomach you're like oh I got
to stop making mix takes what is this I
don't care what fast food I eat if i
order french fries I have to eat every
fry like I get depressed if the fries
start running out like I reach in a bag
up like I know there was more fries in
his bag was the rest of those fries when
I moved the napkin out the way and I
find that one little burnt piece of
crunchy fry I'm like that's what I'm
talking about baby right there my meal
is complete right before today I haven't
to make dollars in like six or seven
months and I was cleaning out my car and
I found some french fries in between the
seats yes and the fries look better than
they did the day that I bought him I was
like how was it no bacteria on these
fries you know how bad of a food you
have to be for mold to be like I don't
eat that horrible food hey I was talking
to one of my friends about I was like
you I found some french fries in between
my seats she was like you found french
fries she said I found a burger in
between my seats I was I want like a
wrapped-up burger she was like no just
to Patty I said cool just a burger patty
in between this seats how dirty is your
car that you could lose a patty I've
never once went to McDonald's who was
eating the cheeseburger and the meat
fell from between the bunny
and I just kept meeting like oh I guess
this is just a ketchup onion cheese
mustard pickle sandwich how do you lose
the patty then I started thinking about
some people's car some people's cars a
filthy they could lose a patty you ever
go to get in someone's car and they
start apologizing as you're getting a
passenger seat hey hey don't worry about
it you can step on all that stuff don't
worry about it aquafina bottles Dunkin
Donuts coz Poland Springs you step
inside the whole time you're riding with
your knees up to your chest
[ __ ] dripping on your toes saw this
stuff on the floor / I feel like they
always have one important thing on the
floor like well step on that that's my
application lays it on the floors my
sister's FAFSA turn it in sometimes I
don't feel like like I don't think I'm a
real man like I don't feel like a real
man like I'm a real man I got real man
parts no you have to say that nowadays
people like I thought a little bit no no
I'm just saying I feel like I don't have
enough tools ties and dress socks to be
a real man I feel like any real man I
know has a lot of tools a lot of ties
like when do you get all those tools
someone's like you get those tools for
gifts I was like if anyone ever bought
me $200 worth of tools I'd be like
return them and get me for PlayStation
games
I don't want tools right Allen Richards
buys Allen wrenches right that's why I
have neighbors I don't have Allen wrench
I don't know I have three tools I have a
Phillips screwdriver I have a flathead
screwdriver and I use my girlfriend's
pliers okay listen you know how
emasculating it is for your lady to be
like did you put my pliers back
I was like I was gonna use the begin
relax I know I'm in Boston one night and
I'm saying this I'm telling this story
I'm talking about not having tools and
everything and this lady the weirdest
thing that's ever happened to me after a
show happened this lady follows me to
the car right I'm walking out the club I
hear excuse me comedian excuse me honey
excuse me you don't have a hammer oh my
god honey excuse me you don't have a
hand up and I was like what ladies
followed me I turn around and she was
like on stage you didn't say you had a
hand my honey and I was like oh yeah I
didn't have the heart to tell our own a
home I have a hammer okay but I had to
go to I was like nah no I don't have a
hammer and she was like oh my god give
me a second this lady runs to her car
she comes back she goes I always keep
two hammers in my car
this lady gives me a hammer after show
you know how weird that is I take the
hammer and I throw it in my truck and I
just thought laughing to myself like I
can't believe I took a hammer from
somebody I just thought about her
getting back in her car making a call
like hello yeah I got rid of the hammer
you guys have been awesome on Cory
Rodriguez
that's hilarious thank
[Applause]